passports and tickets in hand for a
journey many hope will bring peace a
delegation of Houthi rebels waiting to
board their flight to Sweden the UN's
special envoy Martin Griffiths has been
instrumental in setting up the talks
with the Yemeni government such as the
distrust between the two sides
the rebels wouldn't get on the plane
without him our basic guarantee is the
presence of the UN envoy with us on the
same flight this is the only guarantee
we have for going there the evacuation
of 50 wounded Houthi fighters from the
war zone has also helps build confidence
in the talks with the conflict locked in
stalemate
the Houthis backed by Iran controlled
the north west of the country including
the capital Sanaa which they took in
2015 the government backed by Saudi
Arabia and the UAE has set up base in
Aden in the south
four years of conflict have left
thousands dead and created what's been
described as the worst humanitarian
crisis in recent history with Yemen's
economy cripples more than 14 million
people many of them children are facing
starvation it is a country at war as
I've heard many say that this is a
country on the brink of catastrophe this
is not a country on the brink of
catastrophe this is a country that is in
a catastrophe a catastrophe thats
unfolded in full view of the whole world
but one many say has been ignored the
hope is the talks will result in a truce
allowing food and aid to reach those who
need it most for more this morning let's
bring in Guido Steinberg expert on the
Middle East from the German Institute
for International and security affairs
or Berlin think-tank good morning to you
kiddo um will these talks lead to a
truce and a halt in the fighting we
don't know yet I'm slightly optimistic
because one thing has changed since
since 2016 when the last negotiations
took place the United States now exerts
pressure on Saudi Arabia and the UAE to
start the negotiations and to end the
negotiations at least were the truth so
I think we can we can all be slightly
optimist
okay what's behind the new push from the
United States I think we do see the
results of the khashoggi murder the
Trump administration is under jump in
and say that's a Saudi Arabian
journalist the journalist who has been
killed on October 2 in the story
consulate in Istanbul and the Trump
administration is under pressure by
Congress to start sanctions more
meaningful sanctions than it already has
against Saudi Arabia and it seems to me
that the Trump administration wants to
offer a Yemen truce or perhaps even
peace negotiations in order not to
sanction Saudi Arabia and to salvage its
Middle East policy regarding especially
guarding Iran okay so we have new
pressure from the United States the
Yemen conflict is is widely considered a
proxy war between Saudi Arabia and Iran
what motivation would either or both of
these sides have to end the fighting
well Saudi Arabia has has the motive
that it is absolutely dependent
militarily diplomatically
on the United States without United
States military support Saudi Arabia
can't keep up its airstrikes for I would
say more than two or three weeks on the
other hand I do not see it I do not see
the war as a proxy war the Iranian
influence on the whole theory builds in
the country is not really strong we
hardly have an Iranian presence but we
do have a Hezbollah presence perhaps
several dozen milord military advisers
but I see the conflict rather is one
between the two richest States two of
the richest states in the region namely
Saudi Arabia and the UAE against the
Houthi rebels which are to some extent
supported by Iran but it's a sovereign
Houthi decision to stop the fight and
the Houthis are in a very strong
position simply because if they don't
lose they win it's a rebel movement okay
would that mean that that there is a
positive forecast then for the
negotiations looking at this scenario
just laid out well it all it all depends
on the Trump administration and as we
all know the Trump administration is not
not that reliable and Saudi Arabia has
is not the reliable partner anymore that
it was until 2015 so I think we can be
somewhat optimistic but the actors on
the ground especially Saudi Arabia to
some extent the Houthis and the UAE are
not that much interested in conflict
resolution right now they still think
they can that they can win this war but
there might be a truce yes okay thanks
very much Peter Steinberg from the
German Institute for International and
security affairs